[Musique]
bonjour meriem laribi merci beaucoup
d'être ce matin avec nous en direct sur
rt france à partir du 1er janvier dont
cuba va mettre en oeuvre une importante
réforme économique et vous vous êtes
penché évidemment sur le sujet pouvez
vous nous expliquer de quoi il s'agit
précisément meriem oui bien sûr bonjour
à tous les deux j'ai écris donc dans
l'article j'ai décrit dans l'article en
question la série de mesures économiques
que cuba s'apprête à mettre en oeuvre
c'est une réforme que l'on peut
qualifier d'historique et dont le but
affiché est d'actualiser l'économie
cubaine ce qu'on peut en retenir c'est
que le pays va entamer son processus
d'unification monétaire le 1er janvier
qu'est ce que cela signifie donc depuis
1994 vous savez il y avait deux monnaies
en circulation à cuba bleus pesos
cubains et le peso convertible ce peso
convertible qui s'échangeait à un contre
un avec le dollar va disparaître le 1er
janvier il ne restera plus alors que la
paix aux cubains comme seule monnaie
officielle du pays ayem pourquoi les
autorités cubaines ont décidé ce
changement de cap
alors cette mesure est destinée à rendre
l'économie cubaine plus lisible pour les
investisseurs étrangers
comme je l'expliquais dans l'article
elle permettra de sortir de la
multiplicité du taux de change qui
pouvaient brouiller ou fausser la
comptabilité des entreprises publiques
en fait jusqu'ici les deux monnaies qui
ont des taux qui s'échangeait à des taux
très différents étaient l'une ou l'autre
inscrite dans les livres de comptes ce
qui rendait la lecture
l'évaluation de l'état réel de
l'économie cubaine difficile cette
réforme marque également donc la fin de
la double économie entre insulaires et
touristes de cuba jusqu'ici les
touristes vous savez payer exclusivement
en pesos convertibles ce ne sera
désormais plus le cas tout le monde
paiera en pesos cubains que ce soit les
touristes ou les locaux et vous détaille
également plusieurs autres mesures
mérienne dans votre article
oui oui oui j'ai détaillé plusieurs
autres mesures à venir donc sur l'île de
cuba
car l'unification monétaire va
s'accompagner d'autres réformes
économiques qui ont été annoncées par le
gouvernement dans les grandes lignes il
s'agira d'abord d'une dévaluation de la
monnaie locale donc du peso cubain qui
déco qui découlera de l'unification
monétaire
cela fait craindre d'ailleurs une forte
inflation mais les autorités cubaines
ont assuré qu'elle afficherait une
grande sévérité contre la spéculation
notamment dans le marché noir
ensuite il y aura une suppression
progressive de subventions publiques aux
entreprises d'état et aux habitants et
enfin une réforme des salaires et des
retraites des retraites pardon sera
également mise en place pour permettre à
la population d'absorber des
conséquences d'une éventuelle hausse des
prix les salaires et les retraites
seront donc multiplié par cinq a annoncé
le gouvernement cubain et quelle
conséquence les autorités cubaines
attendent tel de cette réforme meriem
oui à ce sujet notamment rapporté les
déclarations du président en cuben
eagles yade cannelle à propos de cette
réforme le chef d'état a prévenu que
l'unification monétaire ne réglerait pas
tous les problèmes du pays que ce ne
serait pas une solution magique pour
sortir de la crise économique selon lui
même je cite
ce sera l'une des tâches les plus
complexes que son pays doit devra
accomplir un pays qui comme il dit est
déjà affectée par les effets du
renforcement de l'embargo américain
la crise sanitaire qui ne les épargne
pas hélas elle la crise économique
internationale c'est donc une réforme
majeure on peut le dire majeur est
risqué pour le gouvernement socialiste
qui tente actuellement de rassurer sa
population sur le fait qu'il ne s'agit
pas d'un programme d'ajustement
néolibérale merci beaucoup myriam à l
arrivée pour toutes ces précisions rt
sur le web comme tous les lundis dans la
matinale d'ayrté france
[Musique]